a part of the revenge of the sith
documentary is this gem here let me just
show you i'm focused on doing that and
then backing up yeah
look at george lucas go this man knows
how to fight using a lightsaber i reckon
if he didn't hold back he would have
completely demolished mace windu and
they're saying he is the sith lord we've
actually been looking for i would have
loved to see george lucas be the main
villain of the star wars sequels that
would have been really fitting and that
would have just been the great end to
the star wars saga jokes aside so in
this scene here we have george lucas
shown ian mcdermott emperor palpatine on
how he wants to choreograph this
lightsaber duel between palpatine and
mace windu and these documentaries for
the star wars prequels and originals are
just complete gems so we want to see
more videos from this let me know in the
comment section below also i've got
another question for you guys if george
lucas was in star wars what color
lightsaber would he have let me know in
the comment section below